[Music]
Nathan dony here with crop King and
today we're going to go through and be
transplanting Our tomato plants for this
upcoming year so last week we went
through and we filled all of the buckets
with the perite and I've had the
irrigation in here running since Friday
to a go through and make sure that
everything's running the way that it's
supposed to it's therefore if I had a
selenoid that was going to fail or a
line that was going to go through and
plug up I'd know that before I had
tomato plants in here um then the other
thing too is to go through and make sure
that we've got that whole meteor profile
moist so we go through and Transplant
plants into here that they're going to
go through and have all the moisture
that they need to go through and get
their initial route started when we go
through and plant we're going to go
through and do two plants per bucket and
then we go through and we've got our top
covers already on top of the bucket so
that that gives us an indication where
our plants need to go and when we start
these plants out we'll take our
irrigation stake and it'll go directly
into the rock wool to go through and
make sure that that rock wo stays moist
until those roots have an opportunity to
go through and root out into the perite
and so then about days 10 or 14 as when
we'll come back through and move those
irrigation Stakes back out away from the
plants into the holes in the top covers
where they're supposed to be so here
we've got half of our top covers so this
goes through and shows us where our
plants are going to go so we make our
little Dibbles here we' go through
transplant the plant into there then
we've got our other half of our top
cover that goes through and sits in the
bucket and then our plants would be here
so we would take our two irrigation
stakes and that would go directly into
the rock wall so again these would go
through and stay here for the first 10
to 14 days and then after the plants
rooted out we'd go through and we move
these Stakes into here where they'd go
through and stay for their duration the
time that we have the crop in the
greenhouse so typically when we go
through and we transplant the tomatoes
they're going to go through and be in
their full sheet 98 counts 1 and 1/2 in
x 1 and 1/2 in Cubes but due to needing
to get the greenhouse cleaned up and
some different things fixed we knew that
we were going to go through and have
these plants a basically a week late
transplanting them so what we did is we
went through and we moved them up into
these grow smart trays so it's a rigid
plastic tray that goes through and has
78 holes and then I went through and we
spaced them out into every other hole to
go through and basically end up with 39
plants in that same 10x 20 footprint
just to go through and give these plants
a little bit of additional space so they
didn't become overcrowded end up shading
the growing points and causing them to
stretch if you knew you were going to be
late and it was going to go through and
be 2 or 3 weeks before you were going to
go through and get those transplanted
you can go through and shift up into the
3X3 grow Cube so basically what this
does is you take that plant and you go
through and you stick it into this hole
here make sure this cube is wet it'll go
through and root out into this Cube
giving you a couple more weeks of growth
before you need to go through and get
that plant transplanted into the bucket
so a grower might decide that they want
to go into these blocks if they know
that the weather's coming in and it's
going to be you know highs of 5° and
they don't want to go through and heat a
5 10,000 ft Greenhouse to go through and
take care of plants that are this size
to go through and occupy that space to
go through and buy them a couple more
weeks wait for a little bit warmer
weather they can go through and heat a
smaller space but give those plants
enough space that they need to go
through so they don't go through and
[Music]
stretch